lange haben wir darauf gewartet jetzt
ist es da das neue iphone se von apple
es gab etliche gerüchte es wurde viel
herum gesponnen seit heute 15 uhr ist
aber klar wie es aussieht und was ist
kann und wir wissen auch es gibt es ab
479 euro ab freitag dann zu kaufen unser
digital experte sven stein ist er ein
glückspilz du hältst das neue handy
schon in den händen sagt uns was ist
tatsächlich so neu an diesem neuen
iphone se ja das iphone se sieht auf den
ersten blick eigentlich aus wie ein
alter bekannter das iphone 8 dass das se
jetzt abgelöst hat es hat in einer
schönen glas rücken hat mit tollen
aluminiumrahmen die entscheiden und die
entscheidende neuerungen stecken im
inneren
es hat einen neuen prozessor drin das
ist derselbe der auch in den absoluten
top modell von apple eingebaut ist
mai von 11 11 home und es hat durch
diesen prozessor neue kappe
funktionen die habe ich testen können
und die machten einen richtig guten
eindruck waren auch ganz nah an der
qualität von den top modellen der preis
ist natürlich vor allem bei apple und
schlagball dann sonst ist man da höhere
rechnungen gewohnt wie ist denn das
preis leistungs verhältnis
also ich finde es sehr gut dass ist der
günstigste preis dem apple je aufgerufen
hat für ein iphone und gerade dank also
nicht nur dieser hochwertigen
verarbeitung die wir gewohnt sind von
apple sondern auch wegen dieser
eingebauten technik die wirklich ganz
aktuell ist bekommst du für einen
verdammt günstigen preis ein sehr
hochwertiges gerät technisch gesehen
die einschränkung ist natürlich dass du
den formfaktor wird das gehäuse hast von
einem gerät das wir schon lange kennen
und man hat so ein bisschen das gefühl
dass es halt etwas altbacken ist aber
das ist halt die einschränkungen in
diesem fall weil es eben dann doch eher
ein kleines einsteigergerät ist er ist
jetzt auf meine frage für wen ist dieses
handys ist tatsächlich eine alternative
für jedermann der sich jetzt schon seit
jahren immer das iphone holt oder ist es
wirklich er für teenies vielleicht das
erste handy na also es ist definitiv
wenn man generell ein handy mit weniger
als 5 zoll bilddiagonale haben will und
dieses gerät hat 4,7 zoll
es ist im moment das beste was du kaufen
kannst am markt definitiv es gibt von
keinem anderen herstellern vergleichbar
gutes gerät in dieser in dieser größe
und daher ist es also nicht nur für
einsteiger sondern auch für alle die
gerne ein kleines kompaktes gerät haben
wollen genau die richtige entscheidung